le pays basque en hiver quand les
touristes sont partis ce sont des
animaux et des hommes pour s'en occuper
[Musique]
mais si nous sommes venus dans ce
village de sare c'est d'abord pour
rencontrer madame arènes donner à qui a
la réputation de faire l'un des
meilleurs gâteaux basques
car madame arènes d'honneur a gardé la
recette du vrai gâteau basque à la
confiture de cerise d'itxassou
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'il faut pour faire le
gâteau basque pour six personnes il nous
en sommes 15 g de farine
oui de 5 g de sucre oui 175 g de beurre
3 e 1 citron et le sucre vanillé et un
peu de levure du paquet de levure
bon ça c'est un gâteau confiture de
cerises confites au rugby oui qu'est-ce
qu'on fait d'abord voilà la farine
genoux rangés le sucre la farine
j'aurai le site rend bien laquelle vos
armes depuis qu il a pris 0,7 et on
mélange donc le sucre la farine tamisée
sirois nier et ce à la mesure levure
chimique
oui d'accord interdisez convient de vous
avez peut être un infâme qui est d'abord
après un gentil on en est plus blanc
oui
et le troisième on enlève le blanc si
way est en berne un tout petit peu pour
dorer de ce jaune pour dorer le bateau
si vous le mettez vous à côté alors
qu'aujourd'hui la moitié du jour de mon
petit peu voilà voilà
ça suffit
je me lâche tout ça bien et après après
j'avais la peur combien de 500 grammes
que jamais ça comme vous voulez et on
recommence à pétrir avoue l'a loupé ça
il faut bien détruire
à quelle occasion mange le gâteau basque
seaska ya pas de fait vous avez
quelqu'un de la famille c'est le gâteau
concert de préférence oui oui un peu de
farine
voilà que ça contre au fond la pâte est
prête maintenant la pâte et les prête le
bien d'homogène voilà alors qu'est ce
que vous en faites
tiens je la mets dans l'assiette enfin
pour ne pas que ça colle les ballons et
vous la jouer mais au frigidaire
bon voilà par malines heure et demie
pourquoi au frigo pour la laisser
reposer
et bien profitons-en pour aller visiter
le village de sare vous allez découvrir
avec nous dans l'un des cafés du village
un jeu de cartes qui se pratique
couramment dans le pays basque et qui
est d'origine espagnole paraît-il c'est
le jeu du mouche ba ba îlots quelles
qualités faut-il pour être un bon joueur
de mouches il faudrait savoir mentir
mais bien vampires et les autres il
faudrait qu'ils reconnaissent quand
l'adversaire mans pour gagner les points
c'est ça qu'il faudrait c'est ça
l'intérêt sans gras il faut le regarder
bien majeur à l'adversaire qui est en
face est-ce que des fois quand tu
manques
il est un peu énervé où il a toujours
quelque chose il apparaît il était en
train de perdre la manche où la partie
alors souvent immenses et gilly vd max a
sauté à la mer
il est moche moche mais on était allé
oui je me posais la pâte
alors vous faites quoi la foule a
maintenant fait je dis oui mais un parti
pas sa gamme un peu moins sont là dessus
alors une petite moitié est une grosse
alors on prend la grosse d'abord oui
grosse blinde france pour faire le fond
oui
ouais
et vous allez la platine
là il faut la force aussi bon parce que
dans le cas de base qu'il ya un fond et
un dessus
ah oui il confie t-il entre on a vous
mettez de la confiture au milieu au
mignon faut que la pâte soit très fine
oui c'est que ça prenne l'échéance tout
me semblait il commence de la tour
thierry voilà comment on fait assez pour
regarder la dimension après maintenant
je les bons sens vous savez après avec
un couteau pour que ce soit assez glee
c'est le travail de précision obligé
parce que d'autres ne la confie thibault
ça n'allait pas l'empêcher de s'en aller
oui donc la pâte ventes bien jusqu'en
haut des bornes
voilà alors qu'est ce qu'on fait
maintenant
la confiture de cerises noires mais il
n'ya pas toujours de la confiture dans
les gâteaux basques n'ont gamins qui
vont pas la traîne oui beaucoup
s'entraîner il me conseille d'attendre à
ce que c'est ça et si on n'a pas de
confiture de cerises noires on peut
employer une autre confiture sans doute
moi j'ai toujours faire et celle ci il
faut que ce passé est assez consistant
en peinture par exemple ça tu rentres
trouve où moi je vais toujours avec
c'est bien alors une fois que la
confiture et est allé qu'est ce qu'on
fait voilà en repli les vosges
nous sommes en repli les bords sur la
confiture unis
voilà et alors et après cela après cela
vous allez étaler la pâte a pas de signe
de dessus oui alors on recommence comme
tout à l'heure ça se fait encore
beaucoup dans les familles le gâteau
basque oui assez alors là on recouvre
donc le le gâteau exactement
voilà ça arrange bien les bords pour pas
que la confiture s'échappe oui des fois
d'arrivée voilà
ensuite je dors avec le jaune d'oeuf que
vous avez gardé tout à l'heure c'est ça
fait des stries la fourchette
alain sens intel en sens inverse
c'est nécessaire ça c'est plus joli sac
garni et on fait toujours le même
dessein moi j'étais toujours la même
liste est longue date au four préchauffé
le poète dépression lui sera instruit
quatre et demi thermostat quatre et demi
ta main packard dell à peu près puis on
regarde de temps en temps des prêts
anglais prêts très bien faite voilà
voilà simplement que j'ai adoré voilà
c'est l'invité peut-être dire merci
sian relierait youri placide pas trop
sucré c'est le meilleur gâteau basque
que j'ai mangé depuis que je suis dans
le pays parce que ça voudrait manger
quelques-uns déjà mais à la confiture
c'est bien meilleur
alors merci à mathieu
[Musique]
bien friands de friable on y croit oui
mais freenews et voilà comment les à
machi c'est comme ça qu'on appelle les
grands mères au pays basque
voilà comment les à match y confectionne
le gâteau basque traditionnel
[Musique]